pfffff
Euh sorry, le bonjour
Attend je te rappelle
He ho ho
Oui oui
Euh, indiquez-moi où il est Notre-Dame de Paris
Eeuuhh.. Notre-Dame de Paris, c'est par là je crois, ouais
Ok faites pas votre Français et dites moi
où il est Notre-Dame de Paris, ok ?
I'm not going a wrong way again...
Je ... Je
comprends pas
Quoi ?
Where is Notre-Dame de Paris ?
Vous les français vous dites toujours le mauvaise direction
Soit vous connaissez pas votre pays,
soit vous êtes des sales racistes de merde
Non !
Je sais pas, vous êtes jaloux de notre puissance mondiale ou quoi?
Non, c'est par là... c'est par là
Ok, ça fait deux jours que je suis à Paris, la capitale du love, ok
Elle pue la pisse, ok ?
C'est dégueulasse, par terre
Look at my sneakers, look at that
Ok you french people are degueulasses
Alors faites un effort, d'accord ?
D'accord ?
- D'accord
D'accord
That's my boy !
That's-my-boy !
Good boy
Donnez-moi votre carte, je vais ...
Je vais voir où on est
Alors, nous...
En plus de pas connaître votre pays, vous êtes super lents, hein
Je reviens jamais en France, hein
C'est vraiment un pays de la merde, hein
La France c'est la chiasse de l'Europe, ok ?
Ok, ok. Heu, donc nous on est là.
Je m'en fous de savoir où on est. Je veux savoir où il est Notre-Dame de Paris
Il est là, Notre-Dame, il est là, Notre-Dame ? Je m'en fous, je veux faire ma photo et je veux me casser, ok ?
Ok. Notre-Dame de Paris,  c'est là.